let's go next - where do we want to go
next let's go next to our caller from
the four to five area code who's calling
today from four to five hi hey Carlton
now let me ask you what kind of device
are we on are we on some kind of headset
or speakerphone gotcha
okay it's it's pretty atrocious but
we'll try to deal with it what's what's
your question today okay right here here
in my state is definitely not the
minimum wage here is like $13 an hour
but I've noticed a lot of like when when
people try to implement a $15 minimum
wage deal corporations tend to try to
wiggle around in a way they don't have
to pay their employees that wage or try
to maximize profits so my question is if
we somehow implements a $15 minimum wage
is this something that we can do to kind
of like make sure inflation doesn't
increase okay well those are two
separate questions so the first question
how so give me an example of how a
corporation would wiggle around if the
minimum wage is 15 an hour how do they
wiggle around that okay so a while back
one of the airports in my state demand
code says it to have a $15 minimum we
have a seat at McDonald's yes so they
said okay we'll give you a 15 on minimum
wage but the downside is they cut back
on employee and put in machines the way
customers can just manually order
themselves right now that the problem
with that argument is that McDonald's
was going to do that either way and
eventually anyway and that those you
know they don't within three months of a
$15 minimum wage they don't develop and
deploy those machines in order to
replace employees that's been in the
works for
for years if not a decade and that's
going to happen either way but that's
where I think we probably get to the
same conclusion which is the $15 minimum
wage is a band-aid in the same sense
that a ubi of $1,000 a month is a
band-aid it doesn't actually resolve the
broader issues of the inequality that
our society creates coming technological
unemployment that what needs to be a
different relationship between humans
and and work so I if if your argument is
a $15 minimum wage doesn't actually
solve the problems inherent to our
economic system I'm right there with you
yeah what happens what the problem is
though is that corporations they're only
in it to maximize profit yes and the
only way they'll maximize profit is
they'll increase the prices of their
goods
well but you have to understand is labor
only represents a piece of the total
cost of an import of a company listen
we've addressed this before and there's
so much crazy noise on your line that
I'm gonna let you go but now we're
getting into material we've we've
already discussed before please call
back next time just on a regular phone
line and I think we'll be able to sort
of hear each other much much better the
car the car Bluetooth stuff is extremely
problematic I reserved it only for
telemarketers in my personal life